[Music]
hundreds of years ago when farmers
needed an extra pair of hands to work
the fields having a child might have
been a purely financial decision but
today unless you are planning on raising
the next Justin Bieber kids are a big
unpredictable cost one that can make
even a normally cool and collected
financial advisor pretty nervous that's
right
Julia and I will soon be embarking on
what will probably be the most rewarding
but expensive adventure of our lives
deep breaths there are so many factors
and variables to having a child it's
really difficult to make even a ballpark
guess of what the total cost will be
especially since these days some parents
will never be totally off the hook from
this financial commitment but just
because you can't plan everything
doesn't mean you shouldn't plan what you
can so here's our beginner's guide to
the general cost you can expect to incur
in your first year of your new family
members life
[Music]
medical bills are notoriously hard to
pin down a 2016 study showed that within
New York City alone the cost for a non
caesarean delivery varied between 4,000
and $17,000 and cesarean sections in Los
Angeles ran between 6000 to $42,000 the
best thing you can do is contact your
insurance provider and get as much info
from them as you can which care
providers are in your network what
procedures are and are not covered and
how much you'll have to pay out of
pocket you want to avoid nasty surprises
like finding out that certain tests
aren't covered or that you can't use the
facility you want make a special
appointment with someone in the billing
department and don't be afraid to sound
stupid drill them for every detail you
can get you should also assume that
you're going to pay your full yearly
deductible during pregnancy and the
first year of pediatric care don't
forget it usually resets at the
beginning of every calendar year Philip
and I have calculated that with prenatal
care ultrasounds clinic costs birthing
coach child birthing classes and sue me
I'm worth it prenatal yoga classes and
massages we're going to pay about fifty
three hundred dollars out-of-pocket just
to get us to the birth there's not a lot
you can do about medical costs but you
can have a bit more control over stuff
like cribs car seats onesies and
strollers this is where family friends
and Craigslist can come in real handy
remember this thing is only gonna stay
the same size for about 0.5 seconds so
don't splurge on items that will have a
short shelf life there are lots of
parents out there who need to offload
the things their kids have outgrown so
far we've only had to spend around a
hundred dollars on maternity clothing
thanks to some friends and serious
thrift we're also anticipating around
300 for a used crib 200 for a bassinet
300 for a fancy but you stroller set 500
for the first year of baby clothes and
another 800 for car seats room decor and
whatever else we might not get from our
registry
[Music]
unless you live in a country with
generous maternity leave
aka not the us a working women will need
to factor in a certain amount of time
off to get her baby through the first
few months your choice is to either set
aside part of your budget in the months
leading up to the birth to build a
maternity cushion or live on a tighter
budget after the baby's born neither
choice is super appealing but either is
preferable to piling up debt the average
baby will consume about 30 ounces of
breast milk or formula a day breast milk
is essentially free while formula costs
on average about 11 cents an ounce so
you're looking at somewhere between zero
and a hundred dollars a month to feed
the little tyke diapers are a bit more
expensive a baby will need on average
about 225 diaper changes a month which
means that depending on the brand
disposables will cost you between 90 and
300 dollars a month
cloth diapers can save you about half
that if you wash them yourself
if you use a laundry service expect to
pay about the same as disposables and
while cloth diapers do cut down on waste
according to one study the electricity
and water required to wash them mostly
cancels out any benefit to the
environment no way around it you will be
adding to adorable little carbon
footprints to the world this is the big
one child care is the number one expense
for most families and it can take a
million different forms there's daycare
nanny share free grandparents hi mum
private nannies or a spouse that stays
at home according to the national
association of childcare resources and
referral agencies the average cost of
center based daycare in the United
States is 972 a month and the average
nanny can cost anywhere from two
thousand to three thousand dollars a
month for full-time care nearly one in
three families report spending 20
percent or more of their household
income on childcare alone the best way
to start nailing down a number is to ask
your friends and family who live in the
same city what their method of childcare
costs them the US Department of
Agriculture also has this handy online
calculator that gives you an estimate of
child raising costs based on your region
and preferences I never really thought
of babies as agriculture but I guess
they do produce a lot of fertilizer
it'll be a long time before Julia and I
really know at the cost of raising this
particular human will be but one thing
we're already glad we did is build up a
three month emergency fund knowing that
we can deal with unexpected costs
without accruing debt helps us sleep at
night only we could save up an emergency
fund of sleep yeah so if you think there
might be a baby in your near future
start feathering your nest with cash now
and remember just because you're gonna
be a new parent doesn't mean you need a
new house or a new car baby won't judge
it's way more important that you're not
financially stressed during those
pivotal first years and that's our three
cents
you